a Fox News host is unable to Define woke
saying woke might just be a feeling or a
sense that you get this coming from the
people who say if you can't Define woman
right now
then you're some kind of
post-modernist wokeest from the
wokeocracy of wokeestan here is Dana
Perino
and this has come up before
when you say woke and you're anti-woke
what do you mean what is woke and we see
it backfire time and time again of
course the reason is that it's been
completely perverted by the right if you
want to talk about a loosey-goosey
post-modern explanation of woke listen
to Dana Perino yesterday on Fox News one
of the things about woke is
president Trump was running and he was
before he won in in 2016. he used to get
standing ovations initially when he
would say political correctness is
ruining our country
and everybody that was clapping knew
exactly what he meant no they didn't see
that's the thing
people clap at Trump rallies without
understanding anything that's going on
this is Dana Perino's first mistake the
you know it when you see it everybody in
the crowd knew what political
correctness was even though Trump didn't
Define it no they don't they're like
trained seals they clap at anything but
it's sort of like the Supreme Court
definition of pornography you know it
when you see it so the Democrats want to
get you in an argument where you're
having to find defined wokeism as if the
Webster's Dictionary is defining it sort
of like you want to get into discussions
with people as if the definition of
woman is what you find in a 50 year old
version of the Webster's it's it's the
exact same thing the criticism they are
making is the one that many on the left
make of them when it comes to the term
woman the difference being the
difference being woke is a term that's
been perverted deliberately by these
folks and that's not what it is it is it
it could be a feeling it could be a
sense and I wonder if Republican or
conservatives are going to have to
Define it more she could be right I
don't know what this this will be yeah
woke could just be a feeling it could be
a it could be a little tingle down your
leg Dana
is wokeism in the room with you right
now where exactly is it this is so
pathetic they say facts don't care about
your feelings and why can't you just
Define what you're talking about if the
wokeness they claim to be so widespread
so noticeable so prominent is nothing
more than a sense what you need a Ouija
board in order to figure out where it is
this is why these people are pathetic
when you actually try to engage them in
good faith about well listen when we
talk about women there's a difference
when we say what is a woman from the
purposes for the purposes of an
obstetrician versus what is a woman when
we're talking about how bathrooms or
Sports should be organized they don't
want to oh no no no that's that's
post-modern nonsense okay like what's
woke well I can't tell you it might just
be a feeling it's a feelings in my in my
arm I can feel the wokeness in my arm
give me a break guys but of course the
hypocrisy doesn't matter we're never
gonna win just by pointing out that they
are hypocrites and so we've got to find
another way forward